i could not believe a movie this hyped
could still surprise me because i was
just expecting to walk into something so
exciting and then i was like wow this
gave me so much more drama and depth and
nuance that i'm like i'm so glad that's
what they led with
[Music]
what's going on there reject nation uh
we just attended the spider-man no way
home premiere and we just want to give
our instant reaction honest thoughts
after watching the movie you guys know
like how much we were looking forward to
this film there's going to be absolutely
no spoilers here i'm going to be
exceptionally careful with how to how to
phrase what we're saying they turned off
all these lights and there was a bunch
of noise earlier so sorry for it looking
a little bit darker than usual the best
the sound's gonna be in the lighting
right now but i had to hop on here
really quick to tell you guys uh how we
felt and i'm just gonna start with
how i felt when the movie was done which
was a
unique feeling something i don't really
get to experience too often when the
credits started rolling and i was
sitting in the crowd i wasn't like
filled with like all this heart pulsing
excitement
i was sitting there in awe
i was sitting there
impressed i was sitting there going dave
they did it they made a pure spider-man
movie and they didn't just make a
spider-man movie they made a great movie
what was funny exciting action-packed
sure the movie breathes well it takes
its time it feels like pure spider-man
with the themes
it chooses to explore the stakes and
consequences are palpable from beginning
to end this is easily tom holland's best
performance that he's done in the like
people i don't think are prepared for
just how freaking fantastic he is in
this movie he is incredible there's more
to touch on before i get carried away
john please
yeah exactly i had a similar experience
with this where you know we watched it
with the crowd that was really into it
that was really responsive that was
cheering and hooping and hollering and
crying and weeping and i definitely had
a lot of those reactions but when the
movie was ended and even
throughout i was just sitting there
going wow this feels like something
special this feels like a moment that i
will remember you know because we see a
lot of spectacular movies
but this really does have that kind of
end game quality where you're like oh
wow they're they're taking a swing and
they're doing something big and what's
awesome about that is it takes a lot of
apprehensions that i know we've shared
about the previous mcu tom hall and
spider-man movies it rectifies a lot of
that stuff with confidence and with hard
decision making i mean this is a
spider-man movie that will give you
certain things that you want but also
it'll give you some things that are
challenging and that hurt
and and whether that be in the emotional
stakes or the action even the action in
this movie was felt
it felt like violence more than action
in some in some cases yeah i was quite
quite uh swept up in this yeah darker
than the trailers let on it's way more
emotional you know how much we cover on
this channel with spider-man no way home
and i was even talking with like cosmic
wonder still full of surprises even
despite all that from beginning to end
and hearing certain things of how they
might go down plot point wise watching
the execution was even surprising in
that regard coy my man the person we are
here because of him we got some special
interviews of red carpet interviews to
show you guys mccoy what do you think
man i think as a spider-man fan it
systematically went through every single
issue i've had with spider-man in other
mediums with the comic books and went
hey i'm paying attention here is the
answer to x y and z and it did it in a
way that felt smooth efficient and
plotted out in a way that i feel like
this was written over the last 20 years
like 30 years 40 years it gave me
spider-man from the 60s it gave me
spider-man with tom holland it gave me
spider-man that felt so true to the
character but it also felt like it fit
with what we've had with tom so far and
the visuals like i i love a good
psychedelic journey and this to me was a
better doctor strange movie than the
doctor strange movie we've had so far
i'm sorry scott i love you this was so
surrealistic and the comedy was maybe
even funnier than homecoming and i think
homecoming might be the funniest
spider-man movie so far i just can't get
over the fact that i laughed and cried
and sometimes both and my tears blended
together and like this this cacophonous
medley of just [ __ ] emotion and it
was spider-man at the end of the day all
of that being said this might be the
most authentic
spider-man movie i've ever seen and
peter parker movie
lights my favorite spider-man movies are
honestly spider-man 2 and the amazing
spider-man the things that i love about
those i'm talking tonal wise exploration
themes that's present here so what i'm
saying like this is one of the best
spider-man movies i'm not talking
strictly in terms of fan service while
there's fan service here as you see
presented in the trailers it's not great
because of fan service it's great
because it's a great movie that's
something i was pleasantly surprised by
john watson's direction in this whoa
this guy learned style whoa this guy
learned he learned he learned the
editing room marvel let him have the
style like
there are stakes and consequences
and there is tension throughout most of
this and just beautiful scene work
michael giaccino's score is brilliant in
this film this is something i wasn't
expecting to say i was rather surprised
by how i felt when it was done green
goblin
holy crap i was like
he's better in this movie than he is in
the first movie i was like how'd they do
that how they feel he's so menacing and
insidious and willing to focus such a
great performance and it feels like a
mix as a comic fan of ultimate
spider-man mixed with 616 norman osborne
there's so much
going on
both in its action and it's pathos with
the goblin there's so much just
happening at you and it really
establishes the character better i think
than we've seen him in live action it's
it's a really astounding performance
yeah i mean what i'll say is that i felt
like with lizard it was two-dimensional
sandman they lost some of the
three-dimensional stuff that you you
know like that you would sort of hope
for at least they still kept the
three-dimensional layers of doc awk and
electro the one that just stood out the
most was definitely green goblin don't
get me wrong they're all good in the
movie yeah they're all enjoyable there
are certain choices they make with
particularly sandman and lizard that i
wasn't too fond of i can't go into
specifics as to why can you kind of
guess what i'm getting at i can't i'm
very excited for a spoiler review yeah
yeah there's a couple of choices you
feel myself over thinking there's a
couple of parts that i was like
i don't know why they chose to do it
that way but okay but they're all
they're all great aunt may's wonderful
in this film everyone in peter's life
that's the thing is mj the foss man the
friends of spiderman when i watched far
from home recently and to give you guys
an idea homecoming and far from home are
closer to the bottom of my ranking when
it comes to spider with the spiderman
films when far from started i was like
why is peter in love with mj where'd
this come from and then it's like
they're cute sure
i really cared about them a lot in this
movie they were they i'm pretty sure
that one part brought you to tears if
i'm not mistaken i tried a few times
not just like one or two just like legit
crying when the movie was done i looked
over at john like his whole face was
just wet
tears to start to come and you're not
even going like you're not sobbing but
they're just they're just coming they're
just going i have to say because of the
unique experience in the theater that my
and i've got to watch them both back to
back but my favorite spider-man movie is
probably into the spider-verse and
because l.a i got to watch this right
next to lord and miller hearing the
moments that they cheered at and feeling
their emotion was exactly the moments i
was feeling so i told john watts after
this was over this is the love letter to
spider-man that i've always wanted to
see in live action and this is the love
letter to silver bronze modern ultimate
every age of spider-man
and i love that john watts just loves
the character and john watts was like oh
i'mma make spider-man this is a
masterpiece i would want to watch it
again absolutely just to be safe
before i give an official ranking of
where it's at but right now i'm a pretty
solid like 9.5 out of 10 on this movie
while i think there are some parts early
on in the film where some of the
dialogue back and forth with some of the
villains was a little bit off to me
because they have to do some catching up
and exposition stuff some of that seems
a little bit off uh while there's some
choices about certain wheels i wasn't a
big fan of nothing to really bother me
immensely but i was kind of like huh
okay for the most part this was an
amazing spider-man movie all puns
intended
yes i mean that sincerely like i i could
not believe a movie this hyped could
still surprise me because i was just
expecting to walk into something so
exciting and then i was like wow this
gave me so much more drama and depth and
nuance that i'm like i'm so glad that's
what the they led with yeah yeah i mean
immediate it hits the ground running and
it throws you into a very tangible
albeit very sci-fi situation and it
doesn't let go and it never loses sight
of what's important you know it's got
the laughs it's got the action it's got
all the things that you want but more
than anything i feel like spiritually
it's on point and that's the important
thing because it's easy to please people
with a spider-man movie it's easy to
have a passable spider-man movie for
people to eat up i thought they really
fine-tuned the actual underlying point
of it all and never let that go and
that's perhaps the best thing i could
say about it for all the fan service all
the things people want that never takes
over the movie to the point where it
loses its spirit at no point did i feel
like this movie was made for anyone
except spider-man fans that's the
highest praise i can give it at no point
did i feel like this was made to appease
blank or blank at no point did i feel
like this was anything except for
spider-man whether it was the drama
whether it was the comedy whether it was
the snark whether it was the love
whether it was the supporting characters
whether it was it was tom this was a
spider-man movie that i cannot wait to
watch over and over again and maybe even
more importantly talk about with
everyone because it's an important piece
of art and spider-man's an important
piece of art there's a reason we all
love spider-man and this is something
truly special this is exceptional this
was this was character driven yeah and
[ __ ] i i can't tell you like how
relieved i was i'm telling you like you
feel like life or death stakes in this
movie yeah that's also what's like you
don't feel safe yeah yeah watch this
movie asap keep a lookout for when we do
a spoiler talk because there's plenty
just one it's gonna be an hour because
this is when i feel myself going like
say the things this is a great movie
very well done see it i also get